Ashton Kutcher and wife mila kunis are  due to welcome baby number two any day  now the expectant father stopped by  conan o'brien show on wednesday where he  revealed he had a name in mind for the  couple's son that didn't make the cut  I'm an Iowan yeah kid named Hawkeye guy  it's like mash like he could be a doctor  yeah cuz no match well hot guys got so  many great it's just such a great cool  name God pakuchek okay I could you yeah  didn't fly no that didn't get across the  Mila threshold no and I came to the  threshold but then it got knocked down  well we see why Mila put her foot down  on that option yeah oh my god the couple  already shares two-year-old daughter  wide Elizabeth who has a pretty cool  name right nomads and we wouldn't be  surprised if her baby brother ends up  with an equally unique name we both love  the name right so I think we have a name  you